and it's interesting too because you
know as you think about healthcare and
the more that you talk to make people
who have spent time in the space like
they realize the body is a machine right
and yeah it's got emotions and kind of
all the things that make us intelligent
life and also but then today is a
machine and agnostic testing and lab
testing is trying to just like you
diagnose what's wrong with your car
right it should diagnose what's wrong
with the body but the processes I'll use
the word broken you may not use that
word but maybe just talk a little bit
about like what are the issues in the
legacy model and then we can get into
kind of what the idea for everything was
and until you've built yeah I mean I
think why health care continues to be
both broken and yet have so many people
try to fix it
to varying degrees successfully or not
successfully is because there are
hundreds of different interrelated and
interwoven factors where you pull one
lever and you make it better you affect
the next and so if you look at this
spaghetti web whether its primary care
whether its specialty care whether it's
hospitals surgeries lab testing
prescriptions these are all factors that
play into an overall what I call
industrial complex that is broken in so
many ways and often because the
incentives are so misaligned not because
any one party is saying I want to not
provide good health care right that is
not the goal I don't believe I really
believe that people's goal is to treat
patients and the most effective way
possible but we don't get there because
it's so broken and so for my experience
specifically and I think what I see a
lot of especially in women's health but
even more broadly as you go to a
physician that physician is either a
specialist or a generalist they are
under immense amounts of pressure
billing time and appointments
documentation all of these things
they're doing the best they can with
limited information and time and then
they have to order tests and then they
to make decisions about what they're
gonna order based on how you relate to
their particular specialty and otherwise
your refer you elsewhere and what I
really think a lot of the problem is
today is a lot of your services are
disconnected from your core physician so
whether that's an MRI or a lab or a
surgery you have all these different
services that your insurance is gonna
get billed for you as the patient don't
know how they relate you don't know what
they're going to cost even with
insurance and then you ultimately don't
have someone coordinating centrally on
what all this means for you unless you
are part of concierge medicine right
which is again to the be reserved for
kind of the wealthy and for people who
can afford that and so I think it is
just a model that needs so much change
and yet there's not one way to change it
it's going to fix it and so you have all
of these different pieces that make it
very difficult to affect change unless
you are in this moment when I think
there's been a lot of good change on the
regulatory front with the pandemic so we
can talk about that later but yeah I
think that's that's the holistic view
that I have I focus a lot on access and
price transparency because those are two
of the particular areas where I think I
can help and where I think a lot of
Americans put particular focus but those
are not the only two issues right it's
so much broader than that that's just
where I think that I can play a role for
sure